I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello! Hi, you guys.
We're really excited today. We're so excited. We can't wait to share this episode with you. This episode's all about The Office BFF's Our Book because... We are in New York City right now for the launch of our book. Oh my gosh, this has been such a long journey. You guys have been with us every step of the way, truly. Yes, your support means so much to us.
And Jenna and I were talking about reading part of our book or sharing part of our book and where we would do that and we were both immediately like, we have to share it with our Office Ladies family first. And you guys sent in so many great questions about the book. We're going to answer them today. You know, we've been doing a bunch of press for the book and one of the things I did was the Gold Digger podcast. Oh, you loved that one.
I loved it with Jenna Kutcher and you know what she said to me, and we keep saying launch of our book and she said, do you know why it's called a book release? Why? That's what I said. And she said, because you release your work into the world. And you let it go. You have to let it go. You work on it.
You make it the best it can be. And then you release it and you have to release it. You have to let it out. Let it go. Oh, I love that. I love that. Right? I did.
I love that. Well, you know, even though this is a special episode of Office Ladies, we still have to have fast facts. I need my structure. You know me. I'm going to do a summary too. Oh, I didn't write a summary. Sorry to disappoint.
Let's do fast facts. I have one. Our book was printed in Willard, Ohio. Okay. And I thought, well, gee, if our book was printed in Willard, Ohio, I want to know a little bit about Willard, Ohio. What you got? Here's what I got.
I went to their official city website, www.willardohio.us. Here are things I wanted to share. The town was founded in 1874, but it was named Chicago because it was the train junction for the Baltimore and Ohio railroads line to Sandusky and the Branch West to Chicago. But guess what? What? People would get confused. I would get confused.
I would be on the train and I would be like, did I make it to Chicago? Illinois? And they would say yes, but I wasn't in Chicago, Chicago. You were in Chicago, Ohio. So they decided to change it to Chicago Junction. Okay. I think I would still be confused as a traveler. I have to be honest with you.
In 1917, to finally rectify the confusion, the town changed its name to Willard after the then president of the Baltimore and Ohio Railroad Company, Daniel Willard. And then Willard became an official city in 1960. Then as of 2019, 6,041, and here are a few things from their website. Their slogan is Proud to Call Willard Home. Listen to how they describe their city, a community where people enjoy living and working, ideally situated with easy access to Ohio's interstates and rail lines. Willard is in the heart of the Midwest manufacturing region, abundant land and utilities, a solid
work ethic, and a progressive local government make Willard the perfect choice for growing a business. We have to go. We have to go. Not only that, here are a few things that are happening just this month in Willard. They honor their hometown heroes. They started doing this in 2018. Each week, a different hometown hero will be recognized on the electric sign at the Willard
City Park as well as through the city's Facebook page. Very good. They have the Willard Tree Program. In partnership with the Willard Moose Lodge 2153, the city of Willard is offering a tree planting program to help property owners plant trees. They also have the Downtown Spring Festival is returning this year featuring the mother of all pickleball tournaments. I love pickleball.
I know. Wait. Cornhole, craft vendors, touch a truck, bike rodeo, and more. Angela, it's becoming very clear to me that we need to go to Willard, Ohio. I know. And that's where our book was printed. Thank you, Willard, Ohio. Thank you, Willard, Ohio.
I also have a few bookstats. Oh, well, you know I love stats. You and Dr. Tipito. Yes. Here are all of our The Office BFF's bookstats. There are 336 pages in our book. There are 440 photos or images in the interior, 440, Jenna. So there are more photos than pages.
There are 16 photos in the endpapers. Okay, so I did not know what endpapers were until we started making this book. That's the part of the book where you open it up and it's like... Part of the cover. Right. It's the back of the cover and then the next little page. And we put all of these amazing black and white photos from the show. I love the endpapers.
They're so special. That we took, by the way, all the photos in the book are our personal photos or photos that were shared with us from our friends on the show. Yes. There's another stat I love. There are 41 pieces of memorabilia in the book. That includes ticket stubs, fan art, posters, brochures, photos of papers and objects and sketches.
All of these things we saved over the years from the show. So one of the pieces of memorabilia is in my chapter, Jam. I have a chapter where I wrote all about Jim and Pam. Lee, my husband, saved his lactation consultant badge. As the nurse. As the lactation nurse. And we scanned it and put it in the book. Love it.
A lot of you wrote in and asked us where all the book will be sold, what countries. We don't have a precise number yet, but definitely United States, Canada and the UK, as well as various English-speaking countries. But as soon as I know all of those countries, I'm going to let you know. The book is also going to be translated into other languages and as we know where it will be coming out, we'll let you know. Well, lady. My fast fact number two is all about the audio book.
We got a lot of people who asked, does the audio book come with access to those 440 photos? No, no, we do not have one of those supplemental PDFs that you sometimes get with an audio book. But we have a bunch of fun audio surprises. So many cool people really showed up for us for this audio book. They did. Reed Bratton wrote an office BFF's song for us, which we used to kick it off. It makes me happy every time I hear it.
I love it. Rainn Wilson wrote and reads a special forward that is exclusive to the audio book. You can't even read it in the hard copy book. You don't want to miss that. And then we have some fun clips along the way from Oscar Nunez, Brian Baumgartner, Kate Flannery, Ellie Kemper, Ed Helms, Steve Carell, and Jennifer Garner. Yes. Kyle H. from Western Mass said, I saw on one of your posts that Jennifer Garner is on
the audio book. How is she connected to the office? Well, Kyle, I don't know if you remember this, but during the pandemic, her and her kids watched the office for the first time from beginning to end. Yes. They cared about it on her Instagram, like their rewatch of it. And when they got to the end for the finale, she had a real good cry. And she posted a video on Instagram, and she agreed to let us interview her about that
experience for the audio book. It's in the chapter finale. She is just delightful. And I love talking to her. She was so gracious with her time. All right, Andrew, you ready for fast fact number three? Yes. It is a fan mail flurry.
What? We really need a sting for fan mail flurry. Sam, what was it, Ange? You were going to make a sting. I'll add it to the list. All right, thank you. We had a lot of questions. Sorry, what was that, an impression?
I don't know. To me, it was like. It's mail coming through a mail slot. Yeah, it's ye olde mail slot. So not magic birds. Yeah, or magic birds. We got a lot of questions about our book tour. Well, let me say this, we are kicking things off in New York City this week.
We are going to be on Late Night with Seth Meyers, the Today Show, live with Kelly and Ryan. And tonight, Wednesday, May 18th, if you are in New York, we will be doing a live event at Town Hall to celebrate the release of the book. But we are so excited for the book tour as well. We are in planning mode. As soon as we have all that locked in, we will let you guys know first. But we're going to spread it out.
We're going to be coming for you till the end of the year is what I'm going to say. Yeah, we're going to enjoy it. We are. It's going to be like a little BFF, like weekend road trip. Yeah, every time we want to get away as friends, we're going to pop up in another city. And the last thing I want to share with you all, because you've been on this journey with me as well, it is official. I have finally figured out my outfits for this book launch.
And there is not going to be a fake flower. Not one. Not one. You know where you're wearing that fake flower? Where? To Willard, Ohio. Yes. We have to go to Willard, Ohio.
And I'll wear a flower. There you go. Before we go to break, Jenna, I'm just sitting here holding our book. We have our books right here. We do. It just looks amazing. And I just want to say a big thank you to Renata. Renata was who was in charge of our book layout.
And Jenna, it's stunning. It's absolutely beautiful. I love the texture of the cover. I love the weight of the pages. These were all things that we had to do virtually. Normally, if you put together a book, not in a pandemic, you get to travel to view the pages. Yeah.
You have a layout meeting. You see what the photos will look like. You do it all over a Zoom. And to see how beautiful it looks in person, I just can't stop thumbing through it. I feel the same way. Thank you, Renata. You really, really knocked it out of the park. Home run.
All right. Well, let's take a break. And when we come back, we are going to answer your questions. And then we're going to read a section from the book. Woohoo! We are back, and we are going to kick things off with Andrea from Virginia. Andrea asked, growing up, did either of you want to write a book? Andrea, I have written two books, and growing up, I never thought I'd ever write a book
at all. I never daydreamed about it. I'm so tickled to be an author, but I didn't think that that would be part of my resume at all. Andrea, I always wanted to write a book. I was obsessed with writing even from an early age. I won a competition at school where I wrote about a lightning bolt. I don't know why we had to write about a lightning bolt, and I got to go up on stage, and I got
a little medal for my writing, and I've always had the writing bug. You've written, like, five television shows. I have, but this was just a culmination, I think, of a dream I've had since I was really little, so it's so special. I have a question from Kate C. in Albany, New York. She says, were both of you equally excited to write a book, or did one of you have to convince the other? Okay.
Okay. That's opening a can of worms, isn't it? Boy is it. Kate, I did not want to write this book. I had written a book, a book that I felt like I had to write with all my soul. That was my book, The Actor's Life, A Survival Guide. That's so good. When I finished it, I said, that's it.
I did it. I'm never doing that again. Done. She did. She did. She told me I am never writing a book again, and so when we had this idea years ago, and we'll get into that, Jenna was like, no, no, no, I can't do that again. I can't do it again.
And I was very naive. I admit it, Jenna. I was just like, what? We'll just sit down and we'll do it. I know what I kept saying. I just prayed it. Angela, I know. I thought the first time, too, it is so much harder than that.
You have no idea. You said, Ange, it will be years before we hold this book in our hands. And I was like, Jenna. Well, that leads me very nicely into our questions from J. Ben R. in Queens, New York. How long did it take you guys to complete the book? And Kristen D. from Grand Rapids, Michigan. What was the entire length of the process from start of book to publication date? Guess what I did.
I went through my digital clutter. Oh, well, lady, I thought since I had a digital clutter sting that you should have one, too. Woo, here it is, my digital clutter. Jenna's digital clutter from her digital pockets. Ah, I feel like I've made it. You have. I love it. Thank you, Sam.
Welcome. This is what I found out. So you guys know that after the office wrapped, we always wanted to work together again. But at a certain point, we started to get really serious. And you probably remember, we were trading messages about it. We traded a series of emails where we made lists of what we could possibly do together. For a job? Yes.
Oh, this is so us. We do, you guys. We make lists. Oh, Jenna. What did it say? Things on the list were talk show. No way. Podcast.
Oh. Uh-huh. We also talked about writing a sitcom for ourselves. And one of the things on the list was book. Wow. I'm sure I immediately said no to that. It was October 19th, 2018, when we were trading these lists. I remember that time.
I remember because we just so desperately wanted a job together. Uh-huh. We kind of write about it in the book. Our last chapter is called Boss Ladies. And it's all about transitioning away from these acting jobs that were taking us all over the world and away from our families into work where we could be home. And these emails were the beginning of that brainstorming. Was Rosé on that list?
No. No. Putting out our own Rosé was not on that list in 2018. You guys, I keep pushing this and I make little labels. Whenever Jenna invites us over for something, I print out a little Office Ladies label and I tape it over like a label on a bottle of Rosé and I give it to Jenna. It's like my subtle hint every time. It's like, you know, it's from the episode with Michael being like, I can manage that.
I can manage that. You're like, you're some Rosé. Right. I'm like, Kelly, you wanted me? Yes. You wanted me? You wanted some Rosé? Yeah.
So, and it was the next year that we did our big garage clean out and we found just the bins of photos and our journals and all of our scraps of paper and ticket stubs. Well, this is when we decided finally to tackle all of our clutter. Yeah. We had been putting it off. Hey guys, tip. If you have clutter and you just don't want to go through it, make your best friend do it at their house too and you will hold each other accountable.
I'd be like, Jenna, I got through three boxes today. I know. And I wouldn't have done any. I'd be like, oh boy. You gotta get on it. Get out there. Well, that is when the idea of our book came up again and we got so serious about it that we called my book agent, Aaron Malone, at WME and said, we might be interested in writing
a book together. Now, this was like a step that we had to our advantage. I had a book agent because I had written a book, so that was very helpful, very time-saving. Very time-saving. And we went into her office. I remember we coordinated outfits. Jenna, I remember we were so excited about this meeting that we even filmed a slow-mo like walking down the hallway.
Do you remember? Yeah. Except I had a boot on my foot because I had hiked my way into a boot. I remember that. So many memories. So she said she loved the idea and told us to write up a proposal. She sent us some sample proposals from books that had dual authors. Do you know how long it took us to write our proposal, Angela?
I took the date on my digital clutter from when she sent us the samples to when we emailed her hours back. Okay. I'm going to guess, five weeks? Eight months. No. Yeah. Why did it take us so long?
Because by this point, we started our podcast. Oh, we had other stuff. We were busy. Yes. We had already gotten to podcasts on our list of possible jobs together. It took us eight months to write a proposal. Eight months just to write the proposal. I bet Erin was like, yes, sure, you guys are going to write a book.
Exactly. Yes, sure. Well, it also took us three solid years to write the book. We even had to push our publication date back twice. I know. So from the first mention of the word book in that email to our publication date, it took us four years and seven months. Wow, Zers.
Mm-hmm. Well, what does that teach you? If you have an idea, don't give up on it. It might take years for you to see it come to completion, but don't give up. Yeah. Well, Jenna, as you were sharing all that, I have this memory of being on my family farm in Texas there with my family. And we were on the phone going back and forth about which publisher should we go with.
We ultimately ended up going with Day Street, which is a division of Harper Collins. But it was a really tough decision. We really loved a lot of the people that we met with that wanted to do this book with us. And when we got off the phone, I walked outside and there was the most gorgeous sunset. Hmm. And you know me, Jenna. I see stuff like that.
And I'm like, oh, this is a sign. We're on the right path. And I have that picture of the sunset. I made Josh take a picture because I was like, I want to remember this moment. Well, Angela, I remember that moment a little differently because I had a pit in my stomach from that moment of decision. I was like, well, we've done it. We've done it.
Angela talked me into it. Oh, no. And now we have to write this book. And I knew, I knew. You had a pit. I was like, look at the sunset. But this is why we're a good team because we trade that back and forth. One of us always sees the sunset when the other one has the pit in their stomach.
Oh, I like that. And that's true. Yeah. Up next is Macy from Lincoln, Nebraska. Macy says, I'm curious what kind of writing rituals you each have. Are there certain times of day, favorite working spots, drinks, or snacks you need? Well, I'll say one thing we have in common is that we both snacked a lot while we were writing this book.
Yeah. As in my pants don't fit anymore. I had to get it. I sized up a pair of pants after writing a book. Same. So if you decide to write a book, snacking is a big part of it. But other than snacking, there is almost nothing about our writing rituals that line up.
Nothing. Except we're both very thorough, but we come to that place very differently. So I like to work in the morning, right after school drop off. That's when I get my best work done are those first morning hours. And you know, just like how you stretch out your body before you work out. Well, I like to kind of stretch my brain. So I got these tips from a writer friend of mine, Laura Tremaine. I love them.
The first thing I would do in the mornings after I got my hot cup of coffee and I sat down at my desk, set a timer and do 15 minutes of reading. It could be fiction reading, nonfiction, it didn't matter. But one of my favorite things that I liked to read was Stephen King's book on writing is very inspirational. It put me in a zone. So then I would set a timer for 15 minutes and do handwritten journaling. Then I would start writing.
I just felt like my brain was ready after those two things. But another thing that I do while I'm doing my warm ups and while I'm writing is I keep a pad of paper next to me. And if I think of a to do item, I write it down on that pad of paper and then I have to keep going because that is a big thing for me is distraction, especially writing at home. I'll think of a chore. I'll think, oh, I have to fold the laundry.
And I would want to get up and go do it. But no, I would write down fold laundry or, oh, I got to get my mom a birthday present. Cannot leave my seat, can't go shop online. I just write it on the pad of paper. Those were some of my little tricks to stay focused. I love all of those. So I write best in the evening. Once everyone's gone to bed and my house is finally quiet.
I love that time just because it's so quiet and I don't have as many distractions. And I turn off my phone and I can feel good about turning off my phone because all my little chicks are in the hen house. They're all asleep in bed and I can just really focus. So here are some of my rituals. First of all, I always had peanuts and M&M's, salty peanuts and M&M's, I had a bowl. I love salt and sweet guys. I would get a cup of tea.
I loved Darjeeling. I would do two tea bags guys, wake up, we're about to write. And then I would have an outline, Jenna and I would work out an outline, sort of like our writing assignment for the day. So I would know what my goal was. I would start my goal, start my writing and then I would do what I would call the big net. I would tell Jenna I'm going to cast a big net.
That meant I had everything in the outline. I had all the information, but now I was going to try to think about all the bigger things that would color in that moment. I would look through old emails, I'd look through journals, I would look at some of the photos and memorabilia and I would just try to uncover every little rock, you know, that reminded me of exactly this moment I was writing about. And then sometimes as I was remembering a story, I would get up and pace, guys, I'm a pacer.
I would talk out these moments that I was about to write as if performing stand up. For example, Jenna, when we talked about the finale of that very last scene that we filmed that was going to wrap the whole entire series. When I wrote that paragraph, I just got up and I talked it out as if I was giving it as a speech. Then I would record voice memos. I often would send them to you. I would say, hey, I just had a brainstorming burst.
I'm going to write this out, but I'm going to talk it out here so we both have it and we can re-listen to it. So those are some of the things that I did. And I actually really liked once we figured out our system because that was a process because you were getting emails late at night and messages from me and I was getting emails early in the morning. Once we figured out how to trade that information, I actually really liked it because I would have all of your thoughts.
You would leave me all your emails and messages as I started writing and I could process everything that you had done that day. And that would inform me of my writing assignment and then the next morning, you would wake up to emails and information from me and you would respond to it as you started your writing process. Yeah. But it took us a while to understand how to trade all of that without just like feeling like we were constantly inundated.
Yes. Well, and through that process, we were also producing our podcast each week. And homeschooling because this was during the pandemic, guys. Our kids were home. I mean, every 30 minutes, I was helping someone, you know, with a math problem or get art supplies or... I mean, all I did during the pandemic was give my children snacks. So many snacks.
So hungry all the time. I know. I found that to be like a sign of like just, you know, unspoken anxiety. We all just wanted to snack all the time. The thing you shared that I think I want to highlight, Ange, is how much non-writing writing involves. Mm-hmm. Like you would spend 90 minutes going through emails and videos and journals.
That is writing. It wasn't words on the page, but that's part of the writing process. Right. The research. Yeah. I would have one day where that's all I did. All I did was like gather, gather, gather, and then make notes and gather, gather. And then it would be the next day that I could then start to form it into a story.
My husband Lee is a writer-director, and most of his day is taking walks, thinking, imagining. You know, he has to create stories from scratch because he writes screenplays. And he's writing when he's doing that. And he's, you know, listening to music for inspiration. That's writing. So many times we left each other messages because we were like, oh my gosh. So it came to me in the shower.
I got it. Oh, showers are a great place for inspiration. I don't know why. And road trips. I remember being in the car. Driving. Driving. I'm playing out these scenes in my mind of like what we want to share.
And I'm like, I got it. And thank goodness for audio memos on your phone because you can say it, I would leave myself notes all the time. So many. Well, Angie, I'm glad we're talking about this because we got a lot of questions from other writers. Mariah P. from Modesto, California said, I love to write, but I get stuck about halfway through a book every time.
What advice can you give for pushing through those writing blocks? Because they can be real self-confidence destroyers sometimes. And Sierra G. from Kansas City, Kansas said, did either of you ever struggle with self-doubt while you were working on your book? And how did you overcome that and find the courage and confidence to even try something new like writing a book or creating a podcast? She also said, thank you in advance for sharing your insight and any practical tips for boosting confidence.
Sierra, I have to tell you, I've written a lot of things by myself, but writing with Jenna was so healing for me because a lot of times when you write by yourself, you're in this vacuum and you can question yourself, like, is this any good? But Jenna was like this constant soundboard for me, but solid and honest, you know? And one of the things I love about our friendship is that we can be constructively, compassionately critical. I remember so vividly, there was one chapter we were working on, we worked really hard on it, and then we ended up throwing it out.
We're like, it doesn't work. It doesn't work. And you had done so much research for it. It was like we were throwing away days of your research. And likewise, though, you had done a lot of work on it too, and we both mourned that, but we knew it was the right decision. I remember we were trading notes and you were like, it just doesn't work. And I'm like, no, it doesn't work.
It doesn't work. Dang it. And I knew it didn't work. But I think having someone you trust that can be a soundboard during your creative process is so important. I also think knowing that you're going to write a bunch of crap. Yeah. Like I don't ever want to go back and read our first attempt at chapter one, Job Opening.
No. Because I've seen glimpses of it, and it is not at all the chapter that it is now. We had to find it, and you have to be able to read your stuff and be like, wow, that's crap. Yeah. And throw it out. And throw it out. It can't be precious.
And I think also just know that the more you do it, the better you get. That is really true for you and I. The more we tinkered on these chapters, because that was the thing I wasn't really prepared for. Because when you write a script for television, you might do a few revisions, but with the book we did revision after revision, years of revision, it felt like. And you told me, gentlemen, when we started this process, Angela, you're going to read this chapter so many times.
Like you're going to read this book so many times. And we did. How many times did we read this book? Hundreds. Hundreds and have notes. And so I just think knowing that where you start and where you finish, there's going to be such a huge learning curve. Our next question is from Jeffrey in Denim Springs, Louisiana.
What's up, Louisiana? Jeffrey says, when we read the book, will it be obvious whether Jenna or Angela wrote it? Yes. Yes. Very obvious because we rotate paragraphs. We really struggled with how do we tell these stories and we decided to tell them the way we share with you here in this sort of back and forth dialogue.
Yeah. The book is a conversation. So you'll see one paragraph will say Jenna and another will say Angela. And there are times when our memories of a certain event do not line up and we both get to tell how we remember it, which is really fun. Really fun. When it's time for Jenna's paragraphs, her name is above it in blue. It says Jenna.
My paragraphs above it, my name says Angela in orange. And my husband, Josh, wanted me to point out that that's Denver Bronco colors. And was that intentional? And I said, no, babe. We didn't pick those colors because of the Denver Broncos. We actually looked at a bunch of different color combinations and those just both popped together. Mm-hmm.
我上面的那些段落里，我的名字是用橙色写的。我丈夫乔什希望我指出那是丹佛野马队（Denver Bronco）的颜色。这是故意的吗？我说，没有，宝贝。我们选这些颜色并不是因为丹佛野马队。我们其实看了很多不同的配色方案，而这两种颜色放在一起刚好很搭。嗯哼。
We liked that combo. Mm-hmm. Well, Melissa S. from Trenton, Ontario and Heather A. from Virginia both wrote in to ask, how will the book differ from the podcast? Will the book have different stories and things we haven't heard before? Yes, it definitely will. You know, this book is our chance to dig a little deeper maybe and especially to dig deeper into our friendship story.
我们很喜欢那个组合。嗯哼。好啦，来自安大略省特伦顿的梅利莎·S和来自弗吉尼亚州的希瑟·A都写信来问，这本书和播客有什么不同？这本书会有我们以前没听过的不一样的故事和内容吗？是的，绝对会。你知道，这本书是我们深入挖掘的机会，尤其是深入挖掘我们的友谊故事。
Yes. It's way more intimate and personal. Not only do you have all these great pictures and things that we saved, it's like we're giving you our scrapbook of our time on the office and our best friendship and the journey of all of that. We're able to go into detail into such wonderful moments that I'm so glad that my kids will have this book. I talk about the time my dad was my date to the Emmys.
是的。它要亲密和私人得多。不仅有所有这些我们保存下来的精彩照片和物件，就好像我们把我们在《办公室》共度时光、我们最好的友谊以及这一切历程的纪念册交给了你。我们能够详细讲述那些美妙的时刻，我真的很高兴我的孩子们能拥有这本书。我谈到了我爸爸做我的男伴去参加艾美奖的那次。
Mm-hmm. It's such a special part of the book for me. And there's a lot of moments like that. It is very different and I'm so proud of it. All right. Well, our next question comes from Natalie in New Jersey. Natalie says, which chapter was the most fun to work on? Jenna and I both answered at the same time to this one, Natalie.
嗯哼。对我来说，这是书中非常特别的一部分。像这样的时刻有很多。它真的很不一样，我为此感到非常自豪。好了，我们的下一个问题来自新泽西州的娜塔莉。娜塔莉问，哪一章写起来最有趣？关于这个，我和珍娜同时回答了，娜塔莉。
Award shows and Hollywood parties. We have a whole chapter about navigating the life of Hollywood and going to these award shows as best friends, all of our hits and misses. There were a lot of misses. When we were brainstorming writing this, we would sometimes have a writing session. That's something we should share. We would get over FaceTime or on a Zoom where we could see each other and we would talk out some chapters, talk out memories.
颁奖典礼和好莱坞派对。我们有一整章是关于如何在好莱坞的生活中游刃有余，以及作为最好的朋友去参加这些颁奖典礼的经历，我们所有的成功和失误。有很多失误。当我们集思广益写这本书时，我们有时会开一个写作会议。这是我们应该分享的。我们会通过FaceTime或Zoom连线，能看到彼此，然后我们会讨论一些章节，讨论回忆。
There were things we definitely wanted to make sure we shared and we would just talk out all of our memories and form that chapter. Award shows was one of the ones we did that. Our next question is from Sally Jane from Fayetteville, Arkansas. What were your favorite and least favorite part of writing the book? I know mine. What are they? My favorite part was just reliving some of these wonderful moments in a way that I might
有些事我们绝对想确保能分享出来，于是我们就把所有的回忆都聊了一遍，然后形成了那一章。颁奖典礼就是我们这样做的其中一章。我们的下一个问题来自阿肯色州费耶特维尔的莎莉·简。写这本书时，你最喜欢和最不喜欢的部分是什么？我知道我的。是什么？我最喜欢的部分就是以一种我可能
not have. You know what I mean? All of these pictures sharing with you, I laughed so hard I cried at a few of the things that we wrote together, Jenna. I don't think I would have written any of that down. I wouldn't have any of this to share with anyone in my family had we not sat down and done this together. That's one of my favorite things is that we have this tangible, amazing scrapbook memory
没有想到的方式，重新体验其中一些美妙的时刻。你知道我的意思吗？所有这些与你分享的照片，珍娜，我们一起写的一些东西让我笑得眼泪都快流出来了。我想我本不会把这些写下来的。如果我们没有坐下来一起完成这件事，我都不会有这些东西可以和家里的任何人分享。我最喜欢的事情之一就是我们拥有了这段切实的、了不起的剪贴簿记忆
of our time on the show and our friendship. My least favorite is easy. All the revisions, all the flippin' revisions. Really? Yes. I like revisions. I know you do. Thank God.
关于我们在剧中的时光和我们的友谊。我最不喜欢的部分很简单。所有的修改，所有该死的修改。真的吗？是的。我喜欢修改。我知道你喜欢。谢天谢地。
But whenever we would get this email, we would get an email that would say, hey guys, here's the book back to you. It would be like a Wednesday and they would say, we would love all your revisions by Friday. I would think immediately I'd be like, I have two days of reading from the minute I wake up to the minute I go to bed. I'm just going to be reading and making notes. I did not like the time crunch pressure of revisions, but I will say my least favorite part of writing is staring at a blank page and having to start a chapter.
但每当收到这封电子邮件，我们收到一封邮件说，嘿，伙计们，书稿发回给你们了。那通常会是个星期三，他们会说，我们希望在周五前收到你们所有的修改意见。我就会立刻想，从我醒来到上床睡觉的每一分钟，我都有两天的阅读任务。我只能不停地阅读并做笔记。我不喜欢修改带来的时间紧迫的压力，但我得说，我写作时最不喜欢的部分是盯着空白的页 面，然后不得不开始写新的一章。
That doesn't bother me as much. That to me is the most terrifying part of writing, going from a blank page to something. Because once I have something, then I can sink my teeth into it. Then I can take away or add or edit. I don't mind editing, but my favorite part of this process and was the first time they sent us the layout of the book, because that's a whole phase. After you lock the manuscript, then they send you your book all laid out in a PDF with all the pictures and seeing it, it's written in the font that it's going to be in.
那个倒不怎么困扰我。对我来说，那是写作中最恐怖的部分，从一张空白页开始写出点东西。因为一旦我有了些内容，我就可以深入其中了。然后我就可以删减、添加或编辑。我不介意编辑，但我最喜欢这个过程的部分，是他们第一次把书的排版发给我们的那天，因为那是一个完整的阶段。在你敲定书稿之后，他们会把整本书排版成PDF发给你，带上所有的照片，看到它，而且是用最终成书的字体写出来的。
That was such an exciting day. I loved that. Moving on, Sid from Logan, Ohio says, out of all of the pictures of the two of you, you feature in the book, which is your favorite? I have to say, Sid, not only are all the photos amazing, they're such personal behind the scenes photos. They're not like anything you've seen. They're not stylized.
那真是令人兴奋的一天。我太喜欢了。接下来，来自俄亥俄州洛根的西德说，在书中你们两人的所有照片中，你最喜欢哪一张？我得说，西德，不仅所有的照片都很棒，而且都是非常私人的幕后照片。它们跟你见过的任何照片都不一样。它们不是摆拍的。
There are pictures. So, in one of them, and Jenna knows the one I'm talking about, we're having lunch in her trailer, my eyes aren't fully open. It is not an attractive picture. It's in the book. It's the only one we had of us eating lunch together. In your trailer. In my trailer.
都是抓拍的照片。所以，其中一张——珍娜知道我在说哪一张——我们在她的拖车里吃午饭，我的眼睛没有完全睁开。那绝对不是一张好看的照片。但它就在书里。那是我们一起在拖车里吃午饭仅有的一张照片。在你的拖车里。在我的拖车里。
So, I was like, it's got to go in the book. It helps tell the story. But in addition to the photos, one of the things I love are some of the sketches that made it in. My post-it note, where I drew a little cat and invited everyone to Sprinkle's birthday party in the parking lot, is in the book. The original one. Well, my favorite photo in the book, I just realized, was my favorite when we did our
所以我当时就想，这张照片一定要放进书里。它有助于讲述这个故事。但除了照片，我最喜欢的事情之一是收录的一些草图。我的便签纸，上面我画了一只小猫，并邀请大家去停车场参加小 sprinkles 的生日派对，那张纸就在书里。原件哦。嗯，书里我最喜欢的照片，我刚刚意识到，其实是我们对书进行
very last pass of the book, because I noticed a detail about it. What? There is a picture of Angela in Curler's, sitting on the steps of her trailer. And if you look closely, she's got half a donut in her hand. And we didn't notice that? For two years. We did not notice the donut. Two years of looking at layouts.
最后一次审校时才发现的，因为我注意到了其中的一个细节。什么？有一张安吉拉穿着发卷、坐在她拖车台阶上的照片。如果你仔细看，她手里拿着半个甜甜圈。我们居然没注意到？两年了。我们竟然没注意到那个甜甜圈。看了两年排版。
It wasn't until the final pass, I was like, oh my God, I'm holding a donut. It's officially my favorite picture. All right, we also got a question from Amro in Palestine, were there any specific moments that made you emotional to recall when you were writing them? I actually cried writing the story about my dad, because my dad has passed away. And just remembering taking him with me to the Emmys, look, I'll cry right now. It was just really special that he got to go with me, and I love that I can share that. And also just reliving what it was like to be in an award show through my dad's eyes
直到最后一遍审校，我才惊呼，天哪，我手里拿着一个甜甜圈。它正式成为我最喜欢的照片了。好了，我们还收到了来自巴勒斯坦的阿姆罗的问题，在写作时，有没有哪个特定的时刻让你回想起来情绪激动？其实我在写我爸爸的故事时哭了，因为我爸爸已经去世了。只要一想到带他去参加艾美奖，你看，我现在就要哭了。他能陪我去真的非常特别，我很高兴能分享这段经历。而且，透过我爸爸的眼光去重温参加颁奖典礼的感受，
also tickled me, because he had some really funny sidebar commentary, because he was a little confused about what all was happening. It just really means a lot to me that that's in the book. Well, there's a chapter in the book called Big Preggs, Little Preggs, Fake Preggs. And that chapter is all about our time being both real and fake pregnant on the office and in real life. We share about what our friendship went through when we became moms. And in that section, I share about going back to work five weeks after having my son, which
也让我觉得很有趣，因为他有一些非常有趣的场边评论，因为他有点搞不懂到底发生了什么。这段经历能写进书里，对我的意义真的非常重大。嗯，书里有一章叫《大孕妇，小孕妇，假孕妇》。那一章讲的全是我们俩在《办公室》拍摄期间以及现实生活中经历真实怀孕和假装怀孕的时光。我们分享了当我们的友谊成为妈妈时经历了什么。在那一部分里，我分享了在生完儿子五周后重返工作岗位，那
was a C-section. And I was not physically or emotionally ready to go back to work. And I explain sort of why I had to go back to work after such a short period of time in the book. But I also share about what Angela did to support me through that time. And it was really emotional for me to recall that time, because I was struggling. And so that was a very vulnerable process for you to just remember it all and put it back down on the page to kind of have to access that again.
是一次剖腹产。我当时在身体和情感上都还没有准备好重返工作岗位。我在书中解释了为什么要在这么短的时间后就不得不回去工作。但我也分享了安吉拉为了支持我度过那段时间所做的事情。回想起那段时光让我情绪非常激动，因为我当时真的很挣扎。所以，对你来说，去回忆这一切并把它重新写回纸上，不得不再次面对那种感受，其实是一个非常脆弱的过程。
But I'm so glad we shared about it, though. Me too. It was actually very healing, I have to say, I think because I got to recall all that support as well. Yeah. Well, Miguel from Mexico sent in this question. Miguel says, we're familiar with your process to deep dive and source from your journals, but still, how can you remember so much?
不过我还是很庆幸我们分享了这段经历。我也是。其实这非常具有治愈作用，我必须得说，我想大概是因为我也重温了所有的支持。是的。嗯，来自墨西哥的米格尔发来了这个问题。米格尔说，我们对你们通过深入挖掘和整理日记来寻找素材的过程很熟悉，但即便如此，你们怎么能记住这么多事情呢？
Well, Miguel, we have a lot of people who help us out. For example, with this book, we did long interviews with our hairstylist Kim Ferry, our costume designer, Carrie Bennett. I traded a gazillion emails with Randy Cordray and James Carey when I was writing about going to Niagara. Yeah. And James and Randy shared photos that they had taken. Guys, the photos in this book you have never seen them.
嗯，米格尔，我们有很多帮我们的人。比如写这本书时，我们和发型师金·费里（Kim Ferry）、服装设计师凯莉·贝内特（Carrie Bennett）进行了长时间的采访。当我写去尼亚加拉瀑布那一章时，我和兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）以及詹姆斯·凯里（James Carey）交换了无数封电子邮件。是的。詹姆斯和兰迪还分享了他们拍的照片。伙计们，这本书里的照片你们绝对没见过。
James Carey has a photo of all of us in our blue parkas on Made of the Mist. Randy has a photo that John and I took as Jim and Pam holding up our hands with our wedding rings on right after we did the marriage scene on the Made of the Mist. I'd never seen that photo before. I said, oh, Randy, can I put that in the book? And he said yes. Amazing. Same with our producer, Steve Burgess.
詹姆斯·凯里有一张我们在“雾中少女号”上穿着蓝色派克大衣的照片；兰迪有一张我和约翰作为吉姆和帕姆，在“雾中少女号”上拍完结婚戏后立刻举起戴着结婚戒指的双手时的照片。我以前从来没见过那张照片。我说，哦，兰迪，我能把它放进书里吗？他说可以。太棒了。我们的制片人史蒂夫·伯杰斯（Steve Burgess）也是如此。
I was trading all of these emails with him about the finale, remembering all the details, and he had a photo from our final table read from a different angle that showed the whole room that I'd never seen before. He graciously let us put it in the book. I love it. We went to dinner with Michael Gallenberg, our production designer, and he gave us some photos of things that we didn't have in our personal collection. And looking through some of his photos jogged so many memories.
我和他交换了所有关于大结局的电子邮件，回忆所有的细节，他有一张来自我们最后一次围读剧本时从不同角度拍摄的照片，展示了整个房间，我以前从来没见过。他非常慷慨地让我们把它放进书里。我太喜欢了。我们和我们的制作设计师迈克尔·盖伦伯格（Michael Gallenberg）一起吃晚餐，他给了我们一些我们个人收藏中没有的照片。翻看他的一些照片唤起了太多的回忆。
Oh, my gosh. He was amazing. Yes. And we included a few of his, Aaron Scherr, Kent Sabornack, Alicia Raycraft, Greg Daniels, Ken Quapas. I mean, guys, we cannot thank you enough for your support, but that's how. It's not just our memories and our journals. It is the relationships we have with other people and their willingness to share their
哦，天哪。他太棒了。是的。我们还收录了一些来自艾伦·谢尔（Aaron Scherr）、肯·萨博纳克（Kent Sabornack）、艾丽西亚·雷克拉夫特（Alicia Raycraft）、格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）、肯·夸帕斯（Ken Quapas）的照片。我的意思是，伙计们，我们对你们的支持感激不尽，但这就是我们如何做到的。这不仅仅是我们的记忆和日记。这是我们与其他人建立的关系，以及他们愿意与我们分享
memories with us. That's how we remember so much. 100%. Kate Flannery and I bless her heart. I can't even tell you how many crazy texts I sent her. Like, Kate, do you remember at the award show when we pretended to have a fake fight? Oh, yeah. We put that in the book.
回忆的意愿。这就是我们为什么能记住这么多事情。百分之百。凯特·弗兰纳里（Kate Flannery）——天哪，保佑她的心。我甚至无法告诉你我给她发了多少疯狂的信息。比如，凯特，你还记得在颁奖典礼上我们假装假打的那次吗？哦，对。我们把那段写进书里了。
I found all our photos of our fake staged fight at an award show. And then, you know, little things like I would text Steve. I said, Steve, what did you do in your office when you were in there? All alone is Michael Scott. And he gave me little details. So I mean, it just, we can't thank people enough. And Miguel, yes. We have definitely gone to our journals and old emails, but what I realized in writing
我找到了所有我们在颁奖典礼上假装打架的照片。然后，你知道的，还有一些小事，比如我会给史蒂夫发短信。我说，史蒂夫，当你在办公室里的时候，你自己一个人扮演迈克尔·斯科特时，你都做了什么？他给了我一些细节。所以我的意思是，我们对大家的感激真是无以言表。米格尔，是的。我们确实查阅了日记和旧电子邮件，但我在这本书的写作中意识到的是
this book is the type of phones we had back then. You didn't really text each other as much. Remember, it wasn't as easy. So what we would do is we would send each other like email updates about our week, our day. We found so many of those. Jenna, remember the amazing one Naomi sent? Yes.
我们当年用的手机。大家其实不会像现在这样经常发短信。记住，当时可没那么方便。所以我们当时会做的是，我们会给对方发送关于我们一周、我们一天的电子邮件更新。我们找到了好多这样的邮件。珍娜，还记得娜奥米发的那封惊人的邮件吗？记得。
My manager, Naomi Odenkirk, when we were writing our chapter, Death Bus, about how the entire cast of the office almost died, Naomi found an email that I had written her about the shoot day where we all almost died three times. And she sent it to me and I was like, oh my gosh. It had so many details in it. Things I didn't remember. Amazing. I mean, hard to believe I didn't remember those details, but I hadn't.
我的经纪人娜奥米·奥登基尔克（Naomi Odenkirk），在我们写关于“死亡巴士”那一章时，讲的是《办公室》的全体演员差点死掉的那次，娜奥米找到了一封我写给她的电子邮件，里面讲的是我们所有人差点死了三次的那场拍摄日。她把它发给我，我当时就想，哦，天哪。里面有太多的细节了。有些我都记不清了。太棒了。我的意思是，真难以置信我居然不记得那些细节了，但我确实忘了。
So thank you, Naomi. So yes, you guys, it took a village basically. That's right. All right. Final question before we go to our next break. We got a lot of questions about our friendship. This book is about our friendship. Ruth from Galt, California said, all right.
所以谢谢你，娜奥米。所以，是的，伙计们，这基本上是靠大家共同的努力才完成的。没错。好的，在我们进入下一个休息之前最后一个问题。我们收到了很多关于我们友谊的问题。这本书就是关于我们的友谊的。来自加利福尼亚州戈尔特的露丝说，好吧。
Have you guys ever had a big fight or drifted apart? We got a lot of questions like this, Angela. People are like, listen, we know your friends, but don't friendships have bumps in the road? People want to hear about them. Of course they do. Well, guys, we do write about this in the book because we did have a big time when we did drift apart. It was right after Angela had her daughter, Isabel.
你们俩有过大吵一架或者疏远的时候吗？我们收到了很多这样类似的问题，安吉拉。大家都在问，听着，我们知道你们是朋友，但友谊难道没有磕磕绊绊的时候吗？大家很想听听这些。当然有。好吧，伙计们，我们在书中确实写到了这一点，因为我们确实经历过一段真正疏远的大时期。就在安吉拉生下女儿伊莎贝尔之后不久。
We write about it in our chapter, Big Preggs, Little Preggs, Fake Preggs. Our lives were just going in two different directions. Yeah. Jenna was entering what I call the sexy life, and I was home with a newborn. And I did not know how to be a good friend to someone with a newborn. I mean, you just sometimes, I don't know, you can't know till you're in it. And we talk about in the book this period of time when Angela was a parent and I was not yet a parent.
我们在《大孕妇，小孕妇，假孕妇》那一章里写到了这件事。我们的生活当时正朝着两个不同的方向发展。是的。珍娜正在进入我所说的性感生活，而我则带着一个新生儿呆在家里。我不知道该如何对一个有新生儿的朋友做一个好朋友。我的意思是，有时候你就是——我不知道，不身处其中你是不会明白的。我们在书中谈到了安吉拉是父母而我还不是父母的那段时间。
And I think that was the point in our lives when we were most distant. We were most distant, but it was all sort of circumstance. It wasn't our heart. That's right. You know? So we found our way back. But yeah, every friendship has bumps. I mean, even learning to build a company together, we've had bumps.
我想那是我们生命中最疏远的一段时期。我们当时是最疏远的，但这都是由各种环境造成的。并不是我们的心疏远了。没错。你知道吗？所以我们最终还是找回了彼此。但是，是的，任何友谊都会有磕磕绊绊。我的意思是，甚至在学习一起建立一家公司时，我们也遇到过坎坷。
Learning how to really and truly how to merge two very different working styles, but at the same time, what we realize is how rich it is. Once we get through that bump and on the other side, we're so much the better for it. So something that is interesting about when we have bumps or when we have conflicts. You know, Angela, you're my person that I vent to about everybody else. I know. Same. So if I'm frustrated with you, oh, it's terrifying.
学习如何真正地、真正地将两种截然不同的工作风格融合在一起，但与此同时，我们意识到的是，这其中有多么丰富。一旦我们熬过那个坎，走到另一边，我们会因此变得好得多。所以，关于我们何时遇到磕磕绊绊或发生冲突，有一点很有趣。你知道的，安吉拉，你是我可以向其倾诉其他人事情的人。我知道。我也是。所以如果我对你感到沮丧，哦，那就太可怕了。
I have to just tell you because you're the person I tell everything to. So we've had moments where I'm like, listen, I got a vent and here's what it is because it's probably me, but this thing is driving me crazy. Right. I'll say that. Like, listen, I know I'm half of this, okay? But the other half is you and we got assorted out. Yes.
我必须得告诉你，因为你是我什么都告诉的人。所以我们有过这样的时刻，我会说，听着，我得发泄一下，事情是这样的，因为这可能是我自己的问题，但这件事情真的快把我逼疯了。对。我会这么说。就像，听着，我知道我有一半责任，好吗？但另一半责任在你，我们得把这事弄清楚。是的。
Yes. But it's so true. I, you know, Josh knows our friendship so well and he's so thankful for it because you get hours of venting that he doesn't have to sort out. And he often will say to me when we've had those bumps, he'll be like, you got to sort it out with Jenna because you're not right. Like you're not quite right. Oh, well guys, thank you so much for sending in your questions.
是的。但事实确实如此。我，你知道的，乔什非常了解我们的友谊，他对此非常感激，因为你可以发泄好几个小时，而这些他都不用去理清。而且当我们在那些磕磕绊绊中走过来时，他经常会对我说，他会说，你得和珍娜去把事情理清楚，因为你不太对劲。就像你有点不太对劲。哦，好吧，伙计们，非常感谢你们发来问题。
We're going to take a break and when we come back, we are going to play an excerpt from our audio book. It's from the chapter, big pregs, little pregs, fake pregs, which is pretty perfect because it's all about our real pregnancies and our fake pregnancies for the show. And next week we're going to be breaking down the delivery. I like it. Chapter 10, big pregs, little pregs, fake pregs. Oh my goodness, Kate Flannery just walked in and she has a piano.
我们要休息一下，回来后，我们将播放有声书中的一个片段。它来自《大孕妇，小孕妇，假孕妇》那一章，这非常完美，因为它讲的全是我们真实的怀孕经历以及我们在剧中的假怀孕经历。下周我们将剖析分娩的过程。我喜欢。第10章，大孕妇，小孕妇，假孕妇。哦天哪，凯特·弗兰纳里刚刚走进来，她带了一架钢琴。
I think she's going to play a song for us. Big pregs, little pregs, fake pregs, babies. Wow, that was so great. Oh, and now Kate's leaving. Bye, Kate. Oh, bye. She just has a piano on her hip. Does she walk around like that?
我想她要给我们弹一首歌。大孕妇，小孕妇，假孕妇，宝宝们。哇，太棒了。哦，现在凯特要走了。再见，凯特。哦，再见。她就把一架钢琴夹在腰上。她平时也这么走路吗？
Maybe so. How talented is she? What a great way to start this chapter because we couldn't write a book about our best friendship without sharing about how we navigated our transitions into parenthood. As anyone with children can tell you, becoming a parent is life-altering. Schedules change, priorities change, and as a result, sometimes even friendships change. We definitely had some bumpy moments once we became moms. We're going to give it to you straight with all the details because that's how we do
也许吧。她多有才华啊？以这种方式开启这一章真是个好主意，因为我们如果要写一本关于我们伟大友谊的书，就不能不分享我们是如何过渡到为人父母的阶段的。正如任何有孩子的人都能告诉你的一样，成为父母会改变一生。日程变了，优先级变了，因此，有时甚至连友谊也会变。一旦我们成为妈妈，我们确实经历了一些磕磕绊绊的时刻。我们会把所有的细节毫无保留地坦白告诉你们，因为这就是我们的做事
it. Also, as you listen to the next chapter, be prepared to hear a lot about wedgies and bodily fluids. You've been warned. While shooting season four of The Office, I was pregnant in real life, but my character of Angela was not, so we had to hide my belly behind all kinds of crazy things. In season six of The Office, Pam was pregnant but I was not pregnant in real life. I wore a prosthetic belly for the show that we affectionately called fake prigs.
风格。另外，当你们收听下一章时，准备好听到很多关于卡档裤（wedgies）和体液的内容吧。你们已经被警告过了。在拍摄《办公室》第四季时，我在现实生活中怀孕了，但我的角色安吉拉没有怀孕，所以我们不得不把我的肚子藏在各种疯狂的东西后面。在《办公室》第六季中，帕姆怀孕了，但我现实生活中没有怀孕。我在剧中戴了一个假肚子，我们亲切地称之为“假孕妇”。
In season eight, Angela Martin was pregnant and I was the one who was fake prigs. In season eight, Pam gets pregnant again but this time I was also pregnant in real life. This back and forth of one of us being real pregnant and one of us being fake pregnant became a source of confusion for everyone. One day on set, our script supervisor, Veta, looked up from her notes and said, wait, who is fake pregnant and who is real pregnant? The journey of our real and fake pregnancies and the way our friendship evolved during those times is the subject of this chapter.
在第八季中，安吉拉·马丁怀孕了，而我是那个戴着“假孕妇”道具的人。在第八季中，帕姆又怀孕了，但这一次我也在现实生活中怀孕了。这种我们俩中一人真实怀孕和一人假装怀孕的来回交替，成了所有人困惑的根源。有一天在片场，我们的剧本主管维塔（Veta）从笔记中抬起头说，等等，谁是假怀孕，谁是真怀孕？我们真实和虚假怀孕的历程，以及我们友谊在那段时期的演变，就是这一章的主题。
Big prigs, little prigs, fake prigs. I got pregnant first. It was the summer of 2007. I was so excited when I found out and I couldn't wait to tell Jenna. It took everything I had not to call her the second I knew but I wanted to deliver the news in person so I decided to tell her at our lunch. Since we usually ate lunch together in Jenna's trailer, I knew that was my best shot at getting her alone.
大孕妇，小孕妇，假孕妇。我先怀孕了。那是2007年的夏天。当我发现的时候我太兴奋了，我迫不及待地想告诉珍娜。我用尽了全身的力气才忍住不在知道的第一秒就给她打电话，但我想当面把这个消息告诉她，所以我决定在我们的午餐时告诉她。既然我们通常在珍娜的拖车里一起吃午餐，我知道那是单独和她在一起的最佳机会。
As soon as I walked in, Jenna launched into a long story about her cat, Andy. This was a common lunchtime subject. Her cat was always doing the craziest things. Oh my god, lady, listen to this. When I went into my kitchen this morning, all the bottom cabinets were open. Like all of them, lady. This story went on for five minutes, you guys. Jenna loved that cat.
我一走进门，珍娜就开始喋喋不休地讲起一个关于她的猫安迪的长故事。这是午餐时间的常见话题。她的猫总是做出最疯狂的事情。哦，天哪，姑娘，听这个。我今天早上进厨房的时候，所有的底柜都是开着的。就像所有的柜子都开着一样，姑娘。这个故事持续了五分钟，伙计们。珍娜太爱那只猫了。
Long story short, Andy had learned how to open the cabinets. I listened, laughed at her story and waited. When she was finished, I blurted out, I'm pregnant. I vaguely remember a thud and shrieking and then after an epic bear hug, Jenna yelled, why did you let me go on and on about my cat? This is accurate, but let me explain the thud. I had been sent to lunch early because we were shooting something that didn't involve front reception.
长话短说，安迪学会了如何打开橱柜。我听着，对她的故事笑了笑，然后等着。当她讲完时，我脱口而出，我怀孕了。我依稀记得一声闷响和尖叫，然后在一阵史诗般的熊抱之后，珍娜大喊，你为什么让我一直滔滔不绝地讲我的猫？这是准确的，但让我解释一下那个闷响。我被提前打发去吃午餐，因为我们当时在拍摄一场不涉及前台接待的戏。
By the time Angela got to my trailer, I was finished eating and had gotten up to do some exercise. I kept five pound weights in my trailer and would do bicep curls or push-ups from time to time and called out a workout. I was trying, okay? So I was pumping iron and droning on about my cat as Angela listened patiently. Mid-curl, she told me she was pregnant. I dropped the weights to the ground, causing the loud thud, then screamed for joy and hugged
等安吉拉到达我的拖车时，我已经吃完了饭，站起来做点运动。我在拖车里放了五磅重的哑铃，时不时会做二头肌弯举或俯卧撑，并把它叫做锻炼。我在努力呢，好吗？所以我当时正在举铁，嘴里还在喋喋不休地唠叨着我的猫，而安吉拉则耐心地听着。就在我做到一半弯举的时候，她告诉我她怀孕了。我把哑铃扔到地上，发出了一声巨响，然后尖叫着欢呼，并拥抱了
my best friend. Our production assistant knocked on the door to ask if everything was okay. Yes, we yelled through our tears of joy. I knew how very much Angela wanted a child. I knew she would make a wonderful mother. I was just so happy for her. In the weeks ahead, I shared the news with the rest of the cast, crew, and writing staff. Everyone was so excited.
我最好的朋友。我们的制片助理敲门问一切是否都还好。我们隔着喜悦的泪水大喊，是的。我深知安吉拉多么渴望拥有一个孩子。我知道她会成为一个了不起的母亲。我只是为她感到由衷的高兴。在接下来的几周里，我把这个消息分享给了剧组的其他演员、工作人员和编剧团队。大家都兴奋极了。
The writers started discussing how they might work the pregnancy into the show and what that might mean for Angela Martin. Then, something crazy happened. The entire television and movie-making industry shut down due to the writer's strike and our show went on hiatus. No one knew how long the writer's strike would last. We had already filmed the first part of season four, and I wasn't showing then. When we finally started production again, four months later, I was seven months pregnant.
编剧们开始讨论如何将这个怀孕情节融入剧中，以及这对于安吉拉·马丁意味着什么。然后，疯狂的事情发生了。由于编剧罢工，整个电视和电影制作行业陷入停顿，我们的剧集陷入了停播。没人知道编剧罢工会持续多久。我们已经拍完了第四季的第一部分，那时候我还显怀。当我们四个月后终于重新开始制作时，我已经怀孕七个月了。
I had a very obvious, very huge belly. The characters and storylines of the show were meant to pick up right where we'd left off. There was no way Angela's character could be pregnant out of the blue. We knew we'd have to hide it, and for that, we had to get creative. Angela did a lot of scenes standing behind the copier or the ficus plant in the bullpen. My personal favorite belly hide was during dinner party. Andy Bernard and Angela Martin arrive at Jan and Michael's party together.
我挺着一个非常明显、非常巨大的肚子。剧中的角色和故事情节本该从我们离开的地方无缝衔接。安吉拉的角色绝不可能无缘无故地怀孕。我们知道我们必须把它藏起来，为此，我们不得不发挥创造力。安吉拉有很多镜头都是站在复印件后面或者办公区（bullpen）的垂叶榕后面。我个人最喜欢的藏肚子场景是在《晚宴派对》（Dinner Party）那一集。安迪·伯纳德和安吉拉·马丁一起到达简和迈尔斯的派对。
The writers were puzzled as to how to disguise her pregnancy as they entered the condo. There was no copier in Michael's apartment. They came up with the idea of having Angela enter with a bouquet of flowers as a host gift. Pam brings wine, Angela brings flowers. They're themselves, right? Oh no. On the day of shooting, the prop team had to keep adding flowers to the bouquet until
编剧们一直在头疼如何在他们进入公寓时掩饰她的孕肚。迈克尔的公寓里可没有复印件。他们想出了一个主意，让安吉拉带着一束花作为给主人的礼物入场。帕姆带酒，安吉拉带花。很符合他们的风格，对吧？哦，不。在拍摄当天，道具组不得不不断往花束里加花，直到
it was enormous. I mean a truly ridiculous bouquet. But that's how we hid the belly. Angela was the first regular cast member to be pregnant on set, so it was as if we were all having that baby with her. Everyone was so protective, making sure she got enough to eat, drank enough water, sat down often enough. The crew even threw her a surprise baby shower in the set parking lot.
它变得巨大无比。我是说一束真正荒谬的花。但这就是我们藏肚子地方法。安吉拉是片场第一个怀孕的常驻演员，所以感觉就像我们所有人都在和她一起孕育那个宝宝。大家都非常保护她，确保她吃得够多、喝够水、经常坐下。剧组甚至还在片场停车场给她举办了一个惊喜婴儿派对（baby shower）。
At that same time, I teamed up with Angela's sister-in-law, Suzanne Daniels, and we threw a friends and family shower. Angela's mom, sisters, and grandmother all flew to Los Angeles for the event. Celebrating Angela's pregnancy with this multi-generational group of women was moving to me. These women, who had raised children of their own, were bringing Angela into the fold. It was a beautiful thing. At the same time, seeing Angela at her baby shower really drove home the fact that I was
与此同时，我和安吉拉的嫂子苏珊·丹尼尔斯（Suzanne Daniels）合作，为她举办了一个亲友派对。安吉拉的妈妈、姐姐和祖母都飞到洛杉矶参加这个活动。与这个多代同堂的女性群体一起庆祝安吉拉的怀孕，对我来说非常感人。这些抚养过自己孩子的女性，正在把安吉拉迎进她们的行列。那是一件美好的事情。与此同时，在婴儿派对上看到安吉拉，真的让我深刻意识到，我距离加入那个行列
very far away from joining that flock. During the same month of the dual showers, Jenna was turning 34. I wanted to be there for Jenna as her birthday approached. She was doing so much for me. But to illustrate the different directions our lives were taking, Jenna wanted to celebrate her birthday at a bar in West Hollywood called St. Nick's. It's no longer in business, but during its heyday, it was a great dive bar. Dark interior, old pleather booths, a jukebox, the best greasy burgers, and a back room with
还有很长一段路要走。就在举办双重派对的那个月，珍娜迎来了34岁生日。在珍娜生日临近之际，我想陪在她身边。她为我做了那么多。但为了说明我们生活正走向不同的方向，珍娜想在西好莱坞一家名为圣尼克斯（St. Nick's）的酒吧庆祝生日。它已经歇业了，但在它的全盛时期，那是一个很棒的小酒馆。昏暗的内部、旧人造皮革卡座、点唱机、最好吃的油腻汉堡，还有一个带飞镖盘的后屋。
a dart board. Imagine being eight months pregnant and walking into that bar holding a sheet cake. Yes, I brought Jenna a sheet cake from the grocery store, and then I waddled to the back of the bar and ate half of it. Angela, I will never forget looking over at you as you happily ate sheet cake and sang at the top of your lungs to Leonard Skinner playing on the jukebox. You were super pregnant in a dive bar, getting all kinds of side-eye from the other patrons. You did that for me, and I am forever grateful.
想象一下，怀孕八个月挺着大肚子，手里端着一个方形蛋糕走进那家酒吧是什么情景。是的，我给珍娜从杂货店买了一个方形蛋糕，然后我蹒跚着走到酒吧后面，吃掉了半个。安吉拉，我永远不会忘记看着你幸福地吃着方形蛋糕，并声嘶力竭地跟着点唱机里播放的林纳德·斯金纳（Leonard Skynyrd）的歌声大声歌唱。你挺着超级大的肚子在一个小酒馆里，承受着来自其他客人的各种侧目。你为我做了那些，我对此永远心存感激。
Well, that is our excerpt for this podcast episode. This chapter was such a blast to write, and we're so excited for you guys to read it or listen to it in the audiobook. Speaking of audiobook, in case you missed it last week, we did a special feed drop, I guess is what it's called. We put the entire first chapter of our audiobook in the Office Ladies podcast feed so you can go listen to that. Yeah, I'll put a swipe up in stories if you missed it, but you guys, before we say goodbye
好吧，这就是我们这一期播客节目的片段。这一章写起来太带劲了，我们非常兴奋能让你们在有声书中阅读或收听它。说到有声书，以防你上周错过了，我们做了一个特别的动态推送（feed drop），我想这是这么叫的。我们在《办公室女士》的播客动态里放了有声书的第一整章，所以你们可以去听听。是的，如果你错过了，我会在快拍（stories）里放一个上滑链接，但是伙计们，在我们今天说再见之前，
today, we have a few wrap-up questions. The first one is from Jill in Marshfield, Ohio. Jill says, obviously, you're best friends, but how would you describe the dynamics of Lee and Josh? Sometimes best friend's spouses are amicable, but there are also times that they just don't mesh. I would say our fellas mesh. So well.
我们还有几个收尾问题。第一个来自俄亥俄州马什菲尔德的吉尔。吉尔说，很显然，你们是最好的朋友，但你们会如何形容李（Lee）和乔什（Josh）之间的相处模式？有时最好朋友的配偶能够和睦相处，但也有时候他们就是合不来。我会说咱们的男人们处得很好。非常融洽。
Yes. And I would say they got along, and they were friends. We would do a lot of group activities together. Whenever we hang out with you guys, afterwards Josh always says to me, Lee's so fun to be around. I gotta hang out with Lee more. That's what Lee says about Josh. But I will say one thing, nothing bonded these men like us writing this book.
是的。而且我会说他们相处得很好，他们是朋友。我们会一起做很多集体活动。每当我们跟你们聚会完，事后乔什总是会对我说，李太好玩了。我得多跟李一起玩。李对乔什也是这么说的。但我得说一件事，没有什么比我们写这本书更能把这两个男人紧紧联系在一起了。
Because they are the only two people on the planet who know what it was really like in those trenches. Jenna, when I showed Josh the book, he was like, oh my gosh, babe, it turned out so great. He was so loving, and we got to the dedication page, and he said, it should just say for Lee and Josh, because we include our children, and he's like, no, it should just say Lee and Josh. Yeah. These guys did a lot of solo parenting on the weekends so that Angela and I could write.
因为他们是星球上仅有的两个知道在那些战壕里真正经历过什么的人。珍娜，当我把书给乔什看时，他说，哦，天哪，宝贝，这本书太棒了。他表现得充满爱意，当我们翻到致辞页时，他说，上面应该只写“献给李和乔什”，因为我们把孩子们的名字也写进去了，而他说，不，应该只写李和乔什。是的。这些家伙在周末承担了很多独自育儿的责任，好让安吉拉和我能安心写作。
They made a lot of space for us. They really stepped up. They were wonderful partners in this book. I mean, it wouldn't be here without them truly. Truly, and I will add this, Lee is a phenomenal writer. He is an amazing editor. I can't tell you how many times we took a chapter to him, and we were like, we think it's done.
他们为我们腾出了很多空间。他们真的挺身而出了。他们是这本书的绝佳合伙人。我的意思是，没有他们，这本书真的不可能面世。确实如此，我要补充一点，李是一个杰出的作家。他是一个出色的编辑。我无法告诉你，有多少次我们把一章拿给他看，然后我们说，我们觉得这写完了。
We really do. Do you have any insight? Do you have any advice we think it's done? And he might have one or two small suggestions that completely changed it and judged it in a way we couldn't have thought of. Yeah. He did a lot of editing of this book, a lot of polishing. I'm sure he's read it dozens of times as well.
我们真的这么觉得。你有什么见解吗？你有什么我们觉得已经写完的建议吗？而他可能只有一两个小建议，就能彻底改变它，并以一种我们绝对想不到的方式对其进行精雕细琢。是的。他对这本书进行了大量的编辑和润色。我敢肯定他也读了无数遍。
He has. And here's my shout out for Josh. Josh is just a technical wizard. Here's an example. We got the book back from Day Street from our publisher, and we wanted to be able to share the document so we could work off one active document. No one could seem to figure this out. Josh did it.
他读过。我要在这里大声夸奖一下乔什。乔什简直是个技术奇才。举个例子。我们从日街（Day Street）的出版商那里拿回了书稿，我们希望能够分享这份文档，以便我们可以基于一个处于活动状态的文档共同工作。似乎没人能搞定这事。乔什做到了。
He made this living, breathing document that we could share in real time. He also helped us recover some photos and memorabilia that I don't know if we could have included in the book without his technical assistance. Like he helped us scan things and create a resolution that was shareable. And I mean, that just means so much to me. So our fellows really came through for us, and I'm glad that we're giving them a shout out here today. Me too.
他做出了这个我们可以实时共享的、充满生机的文档。他还帮我们恢复了一些照片和纪念品，如果没有他的技术协助，我不知道我们是否能把它们收录在书里。比如他帮我们扫描文件并创建了一种可共享的分辨率。我的意思是，这对我来说意义重大。所以我们的男人们真的在关键时刻帮了大忙，我很高兴我们今天在这里大声向他们致谢。我也是。
Well, our final question is from Megan G in Iowa. What big takeaways do you want readers to walk away with and any thoughts you want us to have before diving in? Well, Megan, what I would say is when you watch the office, you're watching a group of people who are becoming good friends. And I mean the cast and the crew. And what we hoped to convey in our book is that intimacy of that group of people. So we have a chapter about holiday episodes on the office, but then we include all of
好吧，我们的最后一个问题来自爱荷华州的梅根·G（Megan G）。你们希望读者看完后带走什么大的收获？在深入阅读之前，你们有什么想法想让我们了解的吗？嗯，梅根，我想说的是，当你观看《办公室》时，你看到的是一群正在成为好朋友的人。我指的是演员和剧组工作人员。我们希望在书中传达的是那群人之间的亲密感。所以我们有一章是关于《办公室》里的节日剧集的，但随后我们还把所有
the ways that we celebrated the holidays off camera together because we're all real friends. Yeah. And I think also, Megan, this book for me is really about friendship. It's the friends we made on set, but it's also finding that friend in your life who builds you up and supports you and is just this unwavering champion for you. And I found that in Jenna and I'm so thankful for it. And I hope our story of our friendship inspires people not to give up, you know, because we didn't think we would make a friend this close and this meaningful in our 30s.
我们在镜头之外一起庆祝节日的各种方式都收录了进去，因为我们都是真正的朋友。是的。而且我想，梅根，这本书对我来说真的是关于友谊的。它是我们在片场结交的朋友，但它也是在你的生活中找到那个能够激励你、支持你并成为你坚定不移的后盾的朋友。我在珍娜身上找到了这一点，我对此感激不尽。我希望我们的友谊故事能激励人们不要放弃，你知道的，因为我们从没想过在30多岁时能结交到如此亲密、如此有意义的朋友。
We thought friendships were sort of things you make earlier in life. And then by the time you're 30, you've got all your friends. But that's when we met. And I would say you just never know who's going to come into your life and to leave that space and openness in your heart. Yeah. I mean, ultimately, this book is about friendship. Yeah.
我们以为友谊是那种你在人生早期阶段建立的东西。然后到了30岁时，你已经有了所有的朋友。但那就是我们相遇的时候。我想说的是，你永远不知道谁会走进你的生活，所以要在心中为他们留出空间和开放的心态。是的。我的意思是，归根结底，这本书是关于友谊的。是的。
So guys, thank you so much. We hope that you like the book. It just came from our hearts and we're really proud of it. I'm sure you can tell. Thanks for going on this journey with us. Thank you so much. So many of you guys have sent in your questions and your comments and your words of support really meant a lot to us over these years.
所以伙计们，非常感谢你们。我们希望你们会喜欢这本书。它完全发自我们的内心，我们为此感到非常自豪。我确信你们能看得出来。感谢你们陪我们走过这段旅程。非常感谢。你们当中有那么多人发来问题和评论，你们的支持之词这些年来对我们意义重大。
And we just can't thank you enough and we're sending you big hugs. We hope to see some of you guys as we release this book into the world. And you know, a big shout out to everyone at HarperCollins and Day Street who helped this book come to fruition. Renata, we've already mentioned, Carrie, Chelsea, Rosie, Peter, Ali, Kel, Suzanne, am I, am I missing anyone, Jenna? Oh, Dennis and Jeremy. I mean, it's a big group.
我们真的对你们感激不尽，我们要向你们送上大大的拥抱。我们希望在我们将这本书带给全世界的时候，能见到你们中的一些人。你知道的，要特别感谢哈珀柯林斯（HarperCollins）和日街（Day Street）的所有人，是他们帮助这本书得以问世。雷娜塔（Renata），我们已经提过了，还有凯莉（Carrie）、切尔西（Chelsea）、罗茜（Rosie）、彼得（Peter）、阿里（Ali）、凯尔（Kel）、苏珊（Suzanne），我是不是漏掉了谁，珍娜？哦，丹尼斯（Dennis）和杰里米（Jeremy）。我的意思是，这是一个很大的团队。
We love you all. It's a big group. Yeah. Thank you. We'll see you next week with the delivery. Part one. Pam's having her baby, folks. It's time.
我们爱你们所有人。这是一个很大的团队。是的。谢谢。下周我们将带着分娩篇与大家见面。第一部分。帕姆要生孩子了，伙计们。时间到了。
Except she refuses to go to the hospital. Oh my gosh. We'll see you next week. See ya. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate
除了她拒绝去医院。哦天哪。我们下周见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副
producer is Ainsley Bubaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
制作人是艾因斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉特恩（Creed Bratton）的《Rubber Tree》。想要无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。在Stitcher Premium享受一个月的免费试用，使用优惠码：OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。